and cheers
every time
so good
morning and welcome everybody this is
teambridge District council's planning
committee on the 15th of February 2023.
thank you everyone for coming I've just
got a few statements to go through
um should the fire alarm ring we're not
expecting any trials for the fire alarm
but please leave the room by the door
behind us and assemble in the car park
please if you've got a mobile with you
please can I ask you to switch off the
phone or put it onto silent
um we don't have any members of the
public with us but obviously that does
also apply to all members of Staff as
well if you've got Mobiles on you thank
you
um
right would members please note that if
they're not in the meeting to hear the
entire debate on an on the application
you can't vote I know that's a
convention but I'm just making it clear
for everybody
so we'll go into the formalities of the
meeting today and apologies for absence
please
thank you chair apologies from
councilors John Patrick Bradford Jeffrey
Nuttall McGregor kurzwell and Cox
Q
um those apologies are noted the next
item to look at is the minutes of the
last meeting
checking the date of them
are members comfortable for me to sign
the minutes as a true record of the last
meeting please can I see a show of hands
thank you I'm not going to vote on that
because I wasn't present myself but okay
thank you
sorry
there wasn't I just asked for a show of
hands
[Music]
and do you want another show of hands
thank you okay
um Declarations of Interest please we
have one item before us today but we
also are noting
um appeal decisions and major decision
summaries any Declarations of Interest
remember today members today
thank you
we don't have any public participation I
kind of I'm telling you what we're not
doing today aren't I and I don't have
any chairs announcements apart from what
I've already talked to you about so we
have to go on to the first item and last
item of the planning meeting today which
is 1901274
Connie Bearwood incurs well with coombe
the planning officer is Gary Crawford
but today we have Roz who's going to be
presenting the item for us thank you
over to you Roz
um this is a reserve matters approval
application planning permission for
development of a single dwelling was
granted in 2016 on this site
um so this Reserve matters application
has been with us since 2019 but um it's
been held up by uh staff availability
issues rather than any particular
difficulties with the application
um so we are uh looking to approve uh
all of the reserved matters today layout
scale access landscaping and appearance
um the site is accessed off uh this
mayor Church Road it has a relatively
long drive and hopefully the next image
will show that it sits uh within a
heavily treed landscape and to the west
of the site is a disused quarry
there we are so you can see that there
are a number of trees across the site
the trees um the site is protected by a
TPO so trees that are authorized for
removal by their spanning permission may
be taken out but the remaining trees
will will continue to be protected by
the tree preservation order
the property as proposed as detailed in
the offices report is large
um it has a basement ground and first
floor and significant
um
width length and is over three stories
as shown on these elevations
um it is made from a composition of
materials including Natural Stone and
other modern material materials it's a
contemporary design but it sits within
the tree landscape and it's not very
visible
um and we think it is a quality design
and an acceptable proposal overall
so
um
prior to granting outline permission for
the replacement dwelling there was a
property on the site that was destroyed
damaged in a fire so these images show
some of the structures that are left on
the site
it's just whirring
the size of the images I think
so there was a more traditional style
dwelling on site where a contemporary
one is now provoked
so the access to the site would be taken
through some Mary Church Road from Mary
Church Road there is an existing access
point that could be opened up if the
site was in another use so they're not
putting in a new access
um it is on a a stretch of Mary Church
Road with with adequate visibility
and that's the end of my presentation so
thank you Jeff
thank you very much we do have the board
member president councilor Haynes and I
believe you wish to speak on this item
thank you chair thank you for allowing
me to speak
um right
I was quite surprised when I saw this on
committee and I'm sorry that I wanted to
come in today just for this one item as
has already been said the application
was in 2019 and it was actually three
and a half years ago that I put in my
request for it to come to committee so
you can understand why perhaps I wasn't
anticipating something happening in this
way
um looking at the reasons for report
under one that the reasons that I gave
at that time
um you'll notice that I I said that um
the the existing local plan allows for
replacement dwellings in the countryside
although it is silent on footprint size
on the replacement that was what the
local plan current local plan says
um we're giving figures there the
previous dwelling footprint 345 square
meters the application for 506 square
meters that's an increase of 161 square
meters
on the original footprint which is
itself more than twice the average
footprint for a dwelling in the country
so you can see what size it is
and since the application was in there
has been further Clarity on on the size
that might be permitted because you'll
be aware that in the local plan that is
the deposit version currently out for
consultation there is a figure given in
that which says
up to 50 percent
so of the existing size so I I accept
and obviously will be guided on the fact
that um the deposit version isn't
doesn't carry much weight I think that's
the term that might still be used but it
does give us an indication of which way
the council's moving
the
application before us is actually the
footprint is 47 larger than the existing
footprint so on that basis it would fall
within uh what we're now looking at as
being the way forward I'll obviously be
very happy for the uh for Ross to come
back and clarify any of these points so
I I find on that basis over the three
and a half years have elapsed I would
have a great difficulty in
um saying that it is uh
too large on the basis that it is just
under 50 which might be seen as being
acceptable but I'll leave that for
members to judge
there is another issue though and
members may have seen the parish
council's comments um towards the end of
the report where they are particularly
exercised by the dwelling that's on site
already which
there were site visits there and it may
be that other members are on those site
visits although they were perhaps 10
years ago
um
there was a caravan put on site not long
after the
um
fire although it may have been a narrow
Valley but it was used for dwelling
purposes so it is then the dwelling
already on site which is described
towards the bottom of page 17 by the
parish council
um
they um
but I note that the Caravan in question
or building as it's now become is not
within the red area shown on the
indicative plan at the start on the
first page of the application details so
I'm concerned that the
use as a dwelling of the additional
structure on the site if this is
approved will itself
have to be permitted by virtue of how
long it's been there given that time's
moved on since this application came in
so there's a couple of questions there
for the officer which I'll be grateful
thank you very much councilor Haynes I'm
afraid I'm turning to you was please if
you've got comments and answers to those
thank you yeah so taking the size Point
first
um our emerging draft local plan is of
extremely limited weight at the moment
but it is a useful sort of rule of thumb
that 50 might be okay and some of us
think maybe that's a bit big if you're
dealing with houses in the countryside
because you could go from a modest
dwelling to a to a large dwelling by
increasing it by 50 but in this instance
whilst the property proposed property is
large there was no size limit imposed at
the outline stage and and the site can
absorb it it's a large site as well
um I've put back up the the site
location plan which um actually the plan
that's on the the cover of your agenda
papers is is as good a plan
um the Caravan that has been put on site
and the enforcement concerns that have
been raised by the parish council relate
to land that is within the applicant's
ownership but outside the red line
um when we granted planning permission
remembering that this is just a reserved
matters approval application if we
needed to tie removal of anything at the
site um other dwellings I'm not sure
they were there at that point but we
should have done it through the outline
we can't put a condition on requiring
the removal of a caravan that's being
occupied as a dwelling on a reserve
matters approval and what we can do
though is make sure that we
um uh give an update to the Parish
Council on the enforcement status of the
site if there are any outstanding
concerns now and within the coming weeks
and and I'm more than happy to undertake
to do that and to get some clarity on
those issues but in relation to the site
itself outline planning permission for a
single dwelling exists and this
application simply seeks approval of
those detailed matters reserved at that
stage
thank you chair
I was just about to just about to ask if
you wanted to comment further I think I
think it's really a lesson to be learned
um obviously for members particularly
because the reason why the Caravan
wasn't enforced against at the time was
because there was permission for a
dwelling on the whole site the whole
ownership
um and then when the outline came in
clearly the only it was a restricted
area excluding the Caravan so I think
the lesson there is that you know you go
along in the belief that something would
go
but a little bit of detail there for the
outline I think is something that you
know got missed certainly I didn't pick
that up at the time uh which means that
you've then got this situation we find
ourselves in now with the other
structure on site thank you
just for clarity chair sorry if I may if
if one of the structures if the
structure constitutes a caravan on site
then we have a 10-year period of taking
enforcement action because its use of
land and which has an enforcement period
of 10 years and if we have stretches
that are not Caravans and that have been
completed or changed used to being a
dwelling than the period maybe four
years but we need to get to the bottom
of that and have a look at what is
actually on site now so we may be in a
position where we can and if we can we
will take enforcement action against
unauthorized residential structures or
properties Caravans or other
um matters whatever they may be at the
site
so can I confirm that's that that's an
assurance that sits alongside this
application yeah I will I am
I've spoken to the team already about
the need for us to refresh and make sure
that we are clear on the enforcement
position in the wider site and we will
update the parish council about uh what
is what is on the site what is happening
at the sites and what we're going to do
about it
um if anything in the near future okay
thank you for that Roz
um are you are you comfortable and with
that counselor hands here thank you
councilor Dewhurst
so I I'm a little concerned
um by councilor Haynes is I I don't
think he means it that way but the sort
of inference that we as counselors
should have picked up on on the the
Red Line issue
um and and in my view that should be
something that should be picked up by
our professional officers who should be
aware of that
um I mean we we've all we've all been
sitting here in this committee for some
time and we understand sort of things
like red lines but but I think I think
it is a big but this goes back to our
enforcement and and I think it is a
concern that it wasn't picked up at the
beginning
um and uh I I think it's the point was
making yeah our enforcement task group
for instance that may be something that
we should report back to that task group
to to make sure that they're aware of
that it just concerns me greatly that
we're we're talking a technicality and
it may be that through a technicality
another dwelling appears in the open
Countryside I got no problem with the
big size yeah I didn't take it as that
actually I just wanted to yeah thanks
for clarity this the structure that I
think we may not be able to take
enforcement action on and we need to be
sure about the dates didn't appear until
after we've made the decision around the
outline planning permission as I
understand it so there's a we've got an
enforcement complaint from 2017 so that
was after we granted planning permission
in 2016. if there is a caravan on the
site as I said we've got 10 years and we
will take enforcement action against
that Caravan if it is being used for
residential purposes at the site we may
need to come back to you for Authority
for that but um we'll we'll do that as
um as promptly as we can but I agree I
think that
um uh we are all improving our practice
all the time again 2015 application and
we would look to and have on other
permissions including near ipupen
actually make sure that we have Caravans
or temporary properties removed from the
site prior to give them permission for
permanent dwellings to try and make sure
that we maintain the number of dwellings
that we've got in the countryside
because we don't think that that's the
sustainable place for people to be
living
okay thank you I've got some other
members who want to come in on this one
please councilor Clarence you are next
thank you very much Jim
Ross is around around the just an
interest run around the community
infrastructure Levy I I remember his
first being introduced on the moderate
sized house I think it was in Shawn at
the time when we granted planning
permission that the community
infrastructure Levy charge on a single
dwelling was around the 33 000 pound
Mark I see here the community
infrastructure level the Civil liability
for this development is
261 pounds and 17p is this a misprint
because it seems absolutely
extraordinary that one dwelling is is
attracting that amount of sale am I just
out of touch
um I say I know there are
ways of not paying the supercharge I.E
you apply for an exemption certificate
for a self-filled and if you live in it
for so many years then you don't to pay
but that's a silly charge I do realize
about that but this seems an
extraordinary amount of money that the
councilor are picking up on one dwelling
are my comments fair or not can you
answer that please
um so it is an extraordinarily large
property and the sell rate outside our
settlement limits is set at 200 pounds a
square meter so when you have a very
large property and a high sell rate and
that 200 pounds a square meter is the
2014 rate so when you've applied
indexation it's actually closer to 250
pounds a square meter now so um and
you've got a large property outside a
settlement limit then they need to pay a
lot of Sil and part of the reason for it
being set at that rate was linked to the
viability of those developments in the
countryside so you you um if you're
developing properties in the open
Countryside they are usually
um targeting the upper end of the market
where the development costs kind of
overall bear that level of of sale
charging rate the charging rate in
Newton Abbott I think or 70 or 75 pounds
a square meter south of Dexter it's 125.
um
it is 18 timoth and dawlish is it up so
that we have it it's um differentiated
by market area across the district
according to to what the the areas
viability can bear so if you're building
a large house in the countryside then
you will have a large cell Bill to go
alongside that and the emerging local
plan is reviewing our cell boundaries
and our civil charging rates
um but I expect that the high
Countryside still charge rate will
persist now thank you for a very
detailed and comprehensive answer that's
put me right and I know where I am and
thank you for the knowledge but you're
right the self-build exemption
um so when we set our still charging
rates food exemption didn't exist so
people who were building one-off
dwellings in the countryside would be
faced with these high sell bills but the
cell regulations were adjusted and
amended so if you are building your own
house or having your own house built for
you you can get a self-built exemption
and if you live in the house for three
years then uh yeah before you sell it as
your main property then you can provide
it that you you know follow the process
that you you can um avoid paying so
thank you so much for a very
comprehensive answer the first class
thank you thank you councilor Clarence I
have councilor Nutley who wants to speak
next please
say thank you chair yeah I think we're
in the wrong business sometimes
um uh just a couple of things
um the existing building that obviously
had the fire when when was the actual
fire on that
a long time ago the other the other
thing that's obviously with the parish
chainsaw I see on here they're saying
there is a dwelling already on the site
um which is used for residential
purposes but not does not have formal
planning uh permission
um they're saying that these structures
should be removed I mean this is
obviously in addition to that is that a
close in proximity to the building
that's going to be filmed
that's already been referred to by um
just you can quickly clarify that yeah
so those structures are outside the red
line so they are associated with the the
former Palm Nursery the growing business
so it's a different planning unit it's
um not on the site that is covered by
this permission okay thank you
councilor Park you were next but it
sounds like that's the answer but yeah
okay yeah
yeah that was to do with the the Palm
form next door I just wondered is that
um in the ownership of the the
applicants in this situation
um because I'm just wondering I was
there when that was opened as a garden
center type thing about 10 or 12 years
ago and and it is quite a large site if
they're Incorporated together and there
is a separate entrance there so would
that be used
um you know in conjunction with this
this application and just one other
further Point um I know you said about
decent Mary Church Road is on a straight
bit of the road but it is a very very
fast Road I know highways haven't got
any concerns about it but there was a
fatality only about um
100 yards away from the entrance there a
few years ago probably speed came into
it but it is a very fast road so
comments on that would be would be
helpful but I was concerned about using
this other entrance from the bomb Farm
any comments on that Rose thank you
um yeah so uh the plan that's on the
front page of your agenda papers shows
the access road and red line uh being
the access
just into the house the Palm Garden
Center access and that property is
within the same ownership as we
understand it at the moment that's what
the application submission says but that
is a separate entrance and a detached
separate planning unit if you like
um so they will be treated separately
um
it is a frustration I've driven on that
road you know it is one that we all use
sometimes to get turned from turkey and
this is an existing access to a house
you know albeit that the house isn't
currently there because it's been burnt
down
um so highways don't have any concerns
because
um uh you're replacing essentially one
dwelling with one dwelling so the level
of usage of that access would be the
same and they haven't raised any further
concerns because it could be reused and
reopened and it is it's out with their
control I think would probably be the
reason why they haven't raised concerns
but
um
that doesn't mean that there aren't
risks to using the highway you know
there's a limit to what we control
um I think is probably what I'm saying
that that yeah it's Mary Church Road can
be very fast and very tricky
um hopefully people will act with due
care and caution when they use it
foreign
thank you I mean we we have got to go
with the the the advice that we've had
from
yeah thank you
um councilor Dewhurst you had another
comment to make
lovely thank you chair
um so you won't be surprised
um
item four on the conditions
um it doesn't seem to sort of specify
exactly what is required when I read uh
the the report
um it it talks about the types of bat
boxes and bird boxes and that type of
thing but he I couldn't actually see
anywhere in in that report that said you
know there will be X number of bat boxes
of this type and why number of that type
and uh said number of bird boxes of that
sort of thing it also didn't mention
anything about Wildlife corridors
through the garden and of course this is
a this is essentially a a woodland open
country area I I might add it's just the
most wonderful place area
um and it also doesn't mention anything
about boat bricks and uh bricks for
Masonry
and I was wondering if um if that could
be
just sort of highlighted in in that
condition number four
well we're in the territory of Reserve
matters I guess but um is there anything
that we can do at this stage for us
um I haven't read the ecology report
um in detail today I did have a look
through the application file when I was
you know signing this report off and
this isn't isn't my case yeah and then
the conditions uh you know they some of
them probably need topping and tailing
before we issue it these are the topics
that it will cover
um I'm more than happy to revisit that
ecology condition and
see whether or not there are adjustments
that we can make to make sure that it is
more specific and also
um
uh you know give it a bit of a
um a boost in line with the um
biodiversity informative that we would
be putting on in any event
um but I I don't I don't I haven't read
it
recently enough of
bricks and Mason B bricks
we do have we do have notes sorry to
interject but we do have notes from the
biodiversity officer with subject to
ecological report safeguards and yeah
provision for bats Birds Landscaping so
it is it's the detail is what you're
talking about yeah
I'm just I'm happy for it to go ahead
and and everything like that I just want
to make sure that we dot the eyes and we
cross the t's thank you okay
are you satisfied that you have enough
from that Roz to
um to take that forward please yes
um I can't see that
um any of that would be difficult to
incorporate into the condition that
we've already got I think that'd be fine
okay so long as that's the case Okay
um I don't have any other speakers
um who wish to make a comment on this
item we seem to have gone through and
I'm getting the feel that people are
happy too
[Music]
and you don't want to put it down okay
okay thanks
also with
the provides out about enforcement on
the other products the other items that
have been discussed I think we've been
through that quite thoroughly actually
thank you councilor Parker
um I think we can
take it forward with everyone is
um consent and go to the vote is it a
recorded vote that we're having yeah
yeah okay raise the hand then please do
recorded vote
I was going to say that's what I saw on
the uh
on the agenda so we'll do a recorded
vote thank you
councilor Clarence
councilor
councilor Dewhurst
counselor hook
counselor Nutley or councilor Parker and
councilor Goodman Bradbury four that's
unanimous Chef thank you
um thank you for that we will now move
on to the next part of the agenda
which is the appeal decisions to note
and I don't believe we
have many comments to make on that but
if you would take it from there please
for us thank you chair no I don't think
there was anything I particularly wanted
to draw your attention to on this list
I'll answer any questions if there are
councilor Clarence if you could wait for
the microphone thank you you had a
comment to make on this yeah
uh yes I do and I don't really you'll
take the question or not
but I hope you might give me in terms of
openness and transparency
I see the the application in Newton
Alberta appeal against refusal of
application and It quotes a reference
uh all right and no I've got the wrong
one excuse me okay
um it was 40 Cent Links Road Newton now
that appears against non-determination
of dwelling in Garden a parallel uh
allowed yep uh
it's just working not working on here
again
appeal against
non-determination
are we running way behind on planning
applications but have we because we've
got an appeal allowed on
non-determination and have we outsourced
about
a hundred or so planning applications to
help our hard-pressed planning
department
and to speed up expedite
um
the lack of non-determination I.E we
need to try and determine things in the
correct period of time so I think we
need to be open and transparent about
this if we have
that my understanding is that we've had
to do this because of Staff shortage
numbers to help the things but I think
it's in the public interest that I've
had a resident come to me at Sean for
example and said I want to do this huge
dwelling and Etc it's in the public
domain all it went on parish council
meeting and he said they haven't even
allocated me a case officer and you know
when am I going to hear about this and
I've got this letter from the planning
department that says I I can go to
appeal for non-determination Council
Clarence you've asked asked a question
about the the appeal allowed I'm going
to ask the officer to answer that and
we'll come back to your um your question
about the the level of applications
thank you very much for taking it
thank you chair
um so
Target time where we're supposed to make
uh I think the target from government is
actually in some instances only as low
as 60 of our decisions within eight
weeks the eight week Target date that
that we're all reasonably familiar with
I think on householder and minor
applications
um if we don't make a decision within
that eight week period or a longer
period that we've agreed then um
applicants are entitled to submit an
application against the
non-determination of the application and
we have
it is not a not a
not a substantial number of
non-determination appeals and still it's
it's you know if the order of half a
dozen
um at the moment
um which are in part a consequence of
people who maybe
um have lost the opportunity to appeal
because they had a refusal too long ago
and they know they're not going to get
an approval from us so they submit an
application and then
um I had one in dawlish where the appeal
was submitted on eight weeks and one day
which happened to be the third of
January before we'd even really come
back to the office a couple of years ago
so it is a tool that's used by by
applicants non-determination appeals if
they think that they won't get approval
from us
um but yes it's fairly well documented
and we are being as open and transparent
as we can both in our letters to
applicants and also in the information
that we provide on the website that we
have a backlog of work at the moment we
are
um uh making Headway into that backlog
and we are
um uh we have a number of contractors
working for us at the moment and we are
looking at uh what routes we can use to
try and process the backlog and
um be in a position where we meet those
Target dates without having to use
extensions of time
um more uh more widely it's something
that is the the key focus of my
management team and I at the moment
trying to trying to get that that
backlog down so yeah we've got a backlog
thank you for that councilor Park you
wanted to come in and then cancel the
dewhirst
thank you and there's actually three of
these appeals actually in my area and
I've got issues with with all of them
but one I want to just bring up a
tongue-in-cheek and Roswell smile when I
started talking about it but um the one
in Sutherland close is in respect of the
TPO that's uh that's um appeal dismissed
regarding the felling of a silver birch
she will know there have been
innumerable applications in the Aller
Park area for this precise type of
Reason felling silver Birches it has and
still keeps coming back to me by
residence the queries regarding this
they're concerned about the condition of
the trees the safety of the trees they
keep coming back and I know Rose is
going to say something like each
application on its own merits and you
know get a report from agriculture
officer Etc I know where it's going but
it's something that just keeps rearing
my head and I just hope that we could
come to some sort of like discussion
about this in this specific area because
it's causing no end of headaches for me
unfortunately not just me but I just
wonder if you make a comment without
Divergent too much
uh well yeah I think um
no no it's fine we we make tree
preservation orders where trees are
considered to be important for wider
amenity purposes fundamentally cheap
preservation orders are about amenity so
they're about the contribution that
trees make
um to either quite local or
um wider Street Scene and sometimes a
tree will be protected because an older
tree has been taken down so I can think
of development schemes where what looked
like relatively small trees are
protected because you've taken down some
larger trees so you might take down one
large tree and then plant three so the
new ones that go in are protected you
see that on
development sites and actually I can
think of one in apple pen and Magnolia
the subject to the TPO even though it
was relatively small
um because the development of some
houses had taken out some bigger cheese
so if trees are important
um in terms of immunity
then we have to consider carefully what
the impact would be of removing that
tree and
um we would only consider trees being
removed if there is a risk of them
falling down and you know if there is a
risk of them dying becoming diseased and
not making a contribution to the area
and and that risk can't just be that's
that a local resident is concerned that
it might fall down it has to be that
there's evidence of land instability or
evidence of it leaning or
um the other thing we get is that people
don't like having a tree in their Garden
because they have to sweep up the leaves
we can't just say that you can take an
important tree down because if these
these other considerations so it needs
to be
um in the public interest that that tree
comes down rather than being in the
private interest and it if you are
suggesting that a tree is dangerous then
really we need to have that from a
specialist tree consultant because then
we can
we've we've got information and evidence
that that we can act on it it needs to
be um it is a technical matter relating
to an aesthetic
um issue so we aren't we aren't able to
to agree to trees being taken down
because they're inconveniencing or or
causing a a general anxiety to people
that that's not what the system in the
framework is there for and I understand
that causes problems for some people
um but that's the system that we work in
like thank you Ross I'm sorry to put you
on the spot there thank you thank you
for that answer and councilor Dewhurst
you wanted to make a comment
thank you chair so just coming back to
the Luke's Road application
um for adrenaline in the garden
um does does
the recent
um publicity about Bristols plans to
have dwellings in gardens does that have
um in a thing to do with the outcome of
that one and also the the final uh item
on that list
22005a this is appeal allowed but it
doesn't say whether it was a committee
or a delegated decision
um so taking those in reverse order the
the castle in one was delegated I don't
know why it doesn't say that I think
that's an oversight I did wonder if that
was a non-deck but it's a slash ref yeah
so um that was a delegated decision and
I uh I know there was some debate in the
office on that one so I think that one
was quite marginal
um
dwellings in gardens
Gardens used to be defined as Brownfield
land and that was taken out of the
national planning policy guidance some
years ago so there used to be an element
of uh presumption uh sort of in favor of
building dwellings in gardens and then
we went through a phase where it was
seen as background development and um
there was a lot of
um noise in the mainstream media about
it being a bad thing to have dwellings
in gardens
um but if you can if you can
find a way where you can deliver
additional housing within the settlement
limit
um of as a scale where immunity is
protected for both the existing and the
proposed property where access can be
accommodated internal and external
amenity can be provided then it seems
like a good idea to me to
intensify the way that we use the land
inside our settlement limits rather than
needing to to you know
expand additionally into Countryside
areas and the create streets Lobby group
talks a lot about gentle densification
and it's one of the ways that we can
achieve gentle densification without
going up because mansard roofs and and
those other Provisions are more
difficult for us if we can provide
additional dwellings appropriately in
back Gardens then then in principle I
would be in favor of it but it has to be
broadly in character with the area good
immunity for the host property and the
proposed property adequate internal and
external immunity space and adequate
access and parking you don't want
somebody's car driving straight past
your living room window you know too
close the proximity issue comes into
play particularly in newer Estates and
then there are issues of character in
areas where you have large dwellings but
in those large dwellings the villas with
grounds we do have a number of those
exact
sorts of properties going forward and
and again I think they can be very much
on balance decisions we've had a few up
at Luke's Road there's some
um in and around Allah there are some
bigger Properties or bigger plots and
some bits of landscaping land that might
look a little bit left over that might
provide these opportunities
thank you very much Roz for a very
thorough answer to that
I think we will now move on to the um
next item which is just the major
summaries
um and we I don't believe have any
comments or any determinations on that
so can I just thank everyone for their
input today and declare the meeting over
thank you for your attendance
foreign